[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على
حضراتكم في هذه الحلقه احنا بستان في
حوارنا مع الدكتور احمد يوسف استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه المرموق اللي كلمنا
المره اللي فاتت
عن طوفان الاقصى لماذا بدا وتوابعه وفي
الحلقه ديت الحقيقه بنحاول نطرح مزيد من
الاسئله في محاوله استقراء المستقبل
القريب واحد من الاسئله المطروحه معي
الدكتور انه بدات المخاوف المصريه من
سيناريو ربما تعد له اسرائيل في ظل هذه
الحكومه المتطرفه ان هي تمارس عمليه شريده
القسوه على غزه اللي اتوا عنها النور
والميه والطاقه والانترنت
وبيستخدموا عمليه قصف وحشي انه يدفعوه
دفعا الى خارج الاراضي الفلسطينيه غزه
ويكونوا باتجاه سيناء الامر اللي ممكن
يعقد المشهد تماما ويدخل مصر على خط
المواجهه هل هذا السيناريو
مطروح
يعني لا
ادعي معرفه تامه بالنوايا الاسرائيليه لكن
دراستي لتوجهات يعني النخبه الاسرائيليه
هي غزه بالنسبه لهم كابوس يعني لا اذكر من
من قاده اسرائيل الذي قال انني اتمنى حين
انام ان اصحوا ليقال لي ان غزه قد ابتلعها
البحر صحيح صحيح اسحاق راين سنه 92 ف
الفكره انه قصاع غزه بكثافته السكانيه
العاليه
وارادته الصلبه وتوجهاته في المقاومه يمثل
بالفعل كابوسا لاسرائيل
وان انه لا شك انه احد السيناريوهات
انه اه ممكن نفرغ هذا القطاع من سكانه
يعني من حقنا ان نقلق انه في حاله يعني
اعمال حق كمين يعني من حقنا في مصر اه ان
نقلق من مثل
هذا السيناريو الس
ا انا لا اريد ان اركز على ان هذا
السيناريو ان وقع ول يقع باذن الله ا سوف
يمثل لمصر مشكله امنيه ولكن الاهم في رايي
انه هذا السيناريو يعني صراحه تصفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه لانه ان نجحت عمليه
تهجير واسعه النطاق للفلسطينيين من غزه
الى سناء على سبيل المثال فهذا نموذج قابل
للتكرار انه كلما مثل الفلسطينيون مشكله
في مكان ما فليكون حلها في خارج فلسطين
بحيث تبقى فلسطين خالصه لليهود وهناك
محاولات سابقه الحقيقه يعني كان في مغريات
شديده للفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه
باعطائهم مدفوعات ماليه وتسهيل كل يعني
خطوات حياتهم الجديده في بعض بلدان امريكا
اللاتينيه وهذا تم على نطار ضيق فهذا
النوع من التفكير
موجود ومن حقنا ان نقلق منه اولا امنيا
واعتقد ان لدينا الوسائل لكي نتحسب تجاه
هذا الاحتمال لان هو المقصود في هذه
الحاله احراج مصر ان هناك يعني عشرات
الالوف يهربون من نير القصف الاسرائيلي
وانتم تسدون الباب امامهم هي المساله ليست
هك كذا المشكله ان اسرائيل تحاول طرد
الفلسطينيين من اراضيهم وما لا يدري احد
ماذا يمكن ان يحدث بعد ذلك ولذلك فان
الموقف المصري يجب ان يقوم في تقديري على
ثلاثه ابعاد البعد الاول تحسب امني لهذا
الموضوع واعتقد انه بايجاده هذا التحسب
الامني لن يحدث هذا
السيناريو البعد الثاني بعد سياسي وهو
التاكيد على معنى ان يعني تهجير
الفلسطينيين من غزه هو نوع من انواع
التصفيه الصريحه للقضيه الفلسطينيه وهو ما
لا يمكن ان تقبل به لا مصر ولا الغزاويين
ولا الفلسطينيون ولا اي فاعل رشيد في هذا
الصراع لانه طبعا ان تم التهجير بنجاح فهو
قابل للتكرار ليس في غزه فقط وانما في اي
مكان وكما ذكرت كانت هناك محاولات بالفعل
البعد الثالث بعد انساني وهو انه اعتقد
انه يتعين علينا في هذه الظروف شديده
القسوه النهارده غزه عباره
عن يعني اسف ان اقول هذا التعبير الاسرا
رايون يريدونها محرقه للفلسطينيين هم اولا
امطارها بالفعل بوابل من القذائف التي
يعني يعلم الله الى اي درجه وصلت نسبه
التدمير فيها لكن الاخطر من هذا انهم
بالاضافه الى الحصار الذي نعرفه لقطاع غزه
الان الكهرباء والمياه وكافه مقومات
الحياه تمنع عن غزه والحقيقه ان الامين
العام للامم المتحده قال قال كلاما مهما
في هذا الصدد واتمنى ان يعني نضغط من اجل
تصعيد هذه المواقف لان في هذا مكسب سياسي
وانساني ده لكن اعتقد ان مصر يتعين عليها
بقدر استطاعتها ان تقدم مساعدات لاهالي
القطاع تدخل الى داخل قطاع غزه مصر كثيرا
ما فعلت ان استقبلت جرحى من غزه لعلاجهم
في المستشفيات المصريه وما الى هذا قد يصل
الامر الى ان يتطوع اطباء مصريون بالذهاب
الى غزه او شيء من هذا القبيل فاذا هناك
بعد امني البعد الامني يتمثل في ايه يعني
لا يعني التحوط ما هو الاقتحام ماه هذا ان
حدث سيكون اما بالضغط او بالاقتحام فالضغط
لن نخضع للضغط ضغط الاسرائيل يعني لا
وايضا قد يعني قد يجد بعض الفلسطينيين انه
لها مفره امامهم او لا نجاه لهم الا
بالدخول الى مصر وبالتالي يجب ان نتحسب
لهذه الضغوط واسسنا في هذا كما قلت انه
هذه تصفيه للقضيه الفلسطينيه ومن جانبنا
نحاول وهذا هو البعد الثالث تقديم اقصى ما
يمكننا تقديمه من مساعدات انسانيه لاهلنا
في القطاع يبقى حضرتك بتقول انه هذا
السيناريو وارد لانه كان دائما وارد في
عقول النخب الاسرائيليه واحد اثنين انه
على مصر ان هي تحول دون هذا السيناريو
تحقق هذا السيناريو ليس لان مصر ممكن ان
تعاني امنيا ولكن لانه ده طبعا واحد ولكن
لانه هذا تصفيه للقضيه الفلسطينيه وعلشان
تمنع هذا السيناريو عليها ان تتحوج
مستويات الاستعداد الامني لاي عمليه
اقتحام او اختراق اثنين الاستعداد السياسي
بتوصيل رساله لكل الاطراف الفاعله ان مصر
ولا الدول الاخرى سوف تقبل بفكره تفريغ
قطاع غزه وبالتالي تصفيه القضيه والامر
الثالث ان يلعبوا دور مصر وغيرها ا بتقديم
اكبر قدر ممكن من المساعدات لهؤلاء
ال لاخواننا الفلسطينيين اللي هم بيتعرضوا
لهذا القذف الوحشي مظبوط معالي الدكتور
تمام هل احنا احنا طبعا طول الوقت بنقرا
على فكره انه بصراحه كده انه في عقو في
العقل الصهيون الاسرائيلي ان سيناء يمكن
ان تكون في نهايه المطاف الحل المثالي لكل
مشاكلهم سيناء بالدرجه الاولى وجزء من
الاردن يعني او او مش جزء من الاردن
والاردن ايضا تكون وطن بديل انت حضرتك
بتتابع القضيه من حوالي 50 سنه هل انت
لمست فعلا في فتره من الفترات او تناه الى
علمك ان هذا السيناريو كان انتقل في بعض
الفترات من الامنيات الى الى التخطيط وان
ده كان قريب من التنفيذ في اي فتره من
الفترات هو طبعا دائما ما كان هناك لدى
الاطراف العربيه المعنيه وهي اساسا مصر
والاردن والى حد كبير ايضا لبنان بسبب كم
اللاجئين
الفلسطينين الموجودين لديها والحقيقه ان
ما يجمع
هذه الدول الثلاثه هو الرفض التام لهذه
الفكره ليس يعني بالنسبه للبنان مثلا هناك
كما نعلم لبنان هو دوله الطائفه فيها تلعب
دورا مهما فتخيل مثلا ان تضيف الى سكان
لبنان حوالي نصف
مليون
فلسطيني المسلمون فيها غالبيتهم من السنه
فهو ممكن ان يؤثر على الميزان الطائفي
بالاضافه للاعتبارات الوطنيه يعني نحن
نستضيفها كاش قء لاجئين ولكن ليس الى درجه
ان يصبحوا مواطنين لبنانيين نفس الشيء
بالنسبه للاردن انه فكره الوطن البديل
ستكون لها تداعيات في منتهى الخطوره على
التماسك
المجتمعي اردني ونحن هنا بالنسبه لنا في
مصر هي مس ممكن نضح دي انا عارف طبعا ان
مع بس يعني لمن لا يعلمنا لمن لا يتابع
يعني كيف يؤثر على تماسك الوحده او
الاستقرار في الاردن ما هو الاردن بعيدا
عن اي حساسيات فيه في شعبه من هم ذو اصول
فلسطينيه ومن هم غير ذي اصول فلسطينيه
الاردنيون يعني الاردنيون فعندما يعني
تدفع بكم هائل من
الفلسطينيين الى داخل
حدود الاردن الحاليه من المؤكد ان هذا
سيثير حساسيات ما وبالتالي هناك موقف يجمع
بين هذه الدول الثلاثه انه لا للتوطين
وبالنسبه لمصريه اتكلمت عن الاردن حساسيه
الوضع في لبنان وحساسيه الوضع في الاردن
وحساسيه الوضع في مصر ايه حساسيه الوضع في
مصر لا اصل هي مساله سياده يعني احنا
متمسكين بانه حق الشعب الفلسطيني في ارضه
و يطرد من ارضه هذه جريمه لا يجب ان
تقبلها مصر يعني ده يعني انا دائما ما
اقلل من الاعتبارات الامنيه لاني احسب ان
مصر قادره على مواجهه هذهه
ا المساله حدث في مره كده اقتحام لحدود
قبل 2012 كان في عهد الرئيس مبارك وفي عهد
ال
الرئيس الراحل محمد مرسي كانت هناك شكوك
على انه في اطار التلاحم بين حكم الاخوان
المسلمين في مصر وحكم حماس في غزه يمكن ان
تكون هناك مرون ما في هذا الصدد لكن صدقني
لا املك من المعلومات الدقيقه ما يمكني من
ان اتحدث بدقه في هذا الموضوع لكن هذا
الموضوع كان مثار قلق في تلك السنه التي
حكم فيها الاخوان المسلمون مصر هل تناهى
الى علم حضرتك قبل ما اسيب النقطه ديت انه
كان في في اي وقت من الاوقات محاوله
لاغراء السلطات المصريه
بمحفزات في مقابل ان يقبلوا بهذا
السيناريو ده بالتاكيد ماه يعني في فتره
احس بنسمع كلام انشائي لكن هل كان لا ليست
لدي معلومات دقيقه لكن يعني عندي ما يشير
الى انه مثل هذه المشاريع لابد ان يصاحبها
اغراءات ماليه اه لكن لكي اقول لك انه في
عهد فلان وفي سنه كذا وعرض كذا يعني لا
املك من الوثائق ما يمكني من ان ادلي بشيء
محدد في هذا الصور طيب السيناريو طبعا
المساله ديت يعني محتاجين نتابعها لانه
اذا استمر اذا سعى نتنياهو الى تنفيذ يعني
تهديداته وظني انه بيبغ كثيرا
يعني فاحنا هنكون قدام سيناريو هذا
السيناريو ربما يكون وشيكا ان احنا نتعامل
معاه يعني انا احسب انه لابد ان السلطات
المصريه تدرك هذا جيدا و واتخذت بالفعل ما
يمكنها من مواجهه هذا السيناريو ان حدث هم
امبارح انا سمعت طبعا انت عارف حضرتك
طريقه الدول بصفه عامه يعني فبقت في
تصريحات منسوبه الى مصدر يعني غير مسمى
يعني او مجهل بيحذر اسرائيل من هذا
السيناريو وان سيادتنا ده هو بيقول ان
السياده المصريه يعني ليست مستباحه على كل
الاحوال سوف نتابع انا عندي سؤال تاني
معالي الدكتور انه الوضع الحالي بيفرض
علينا سؤال على مستقبل السلطه الفلسطينيه
اصلا احنا عندنا سلطتين السلطه اللي هي
المفروض انها ممثله لكل فلسطينيين اللي هي
السلطه الفلسطينيه بقياده الرئيس ابو مازن
محمود عباس وعندنا ودي لا تحكم سيطرتها
الا على الضفه وعندنا السلطه الفعليه اللي
موجوده في غزه اللي هي الجمعات ولكن
تحديدا جماعه
حماس انا اسف ان انا اصيغها بهذا الشكل بس
انا بعبر عن
نفسي واقع الامر ان السلطه ليس لها دور لا
هي قادره على تحقيق برنامجها في المهادنه
او السلام مع اسرائيل ولا هي قادره على
الردع والمقاومه فاصبح لما حد عاوز يترق
الابواب هو بيروح ل حماس او
الجهاد السلطه الفلسطينيه اصبح دورها مجرد
تسيير للشؤون اليوميه للمواطنين في الضفه
هل هذا يعني ممكن
يستمر هو شوف حضرتك عندما
ا نشا السلطه الفلسطينيه بعد اتفاقيات
اوسلو كان لدينا
جميعا في 93 في اظن 944 او شيء من هذا
القبيل كان لدينا جميعا الامل في ان ان
تكون السلطه الفلسطينيه هي نواه الدوله
الفلسطينيه وعندما اقول الدوله الفلسطينيه
اقصد الدوله الفلسطينيه ذات السياده الى
اخره وكان هذا الامل معقودا على ان يسير
تسير خريطه الطريق التي تضمنتها اتفاقيه
اسلو سيرا طبيعيا بحيث نصل في النهايه
الاتفاقيه اسلو لو نذكر حددت خمس سنوات
كمرحله انتقاليه يتم فيها تسويه قضايا
الوضع النهائي السنوات الخمسه دي بدات ب
1994 وكان المفروض تنتهي في
1999 ونذكر ان الرئيس ياسر عرفات اظن
عندما انتهت هذه الفتره اعلن قيام دوله
فلسطين طبعا هي كان سبق اعلنت في
الثمانينات لكن كانه يعلنها بناء على
اتفاقيه اسلو لكن طبعا هذا الاعلان لم يكن
له تجسيد على ارض الواقع لان السلطه ظلت
السلطه السلطه طبعا واجهت
مشاكل منها مثلا ان اسرائيل تعوق عملها ان
لم تعجبها تصرفات السلطه
تمنع وصول الموارد الماليه التي تستحقها
نتيجه الاتفاق مع السلطات الاسرائيليه
تخترق اراضي الحكم الذاتي الفلسطيني دون
يعني
هواده بالضبط وتفعل فيها ما تشاء من
اعتداء على الفلسطينيين ووى اخره وبالتالي
السلطه الفلسطينيه واجهت مشاكل جمه من
اسرائيل ولكنها واجهت مشاكل داخليه ايضا
جمه تمثل في الانقسام بين حماس وبين فتح
وهو للاسف انقسام ظل قائما منذ 2007 حتى
الان رغم انني احصيت 11 وربما 12 محاوله
للتوسط كان اخرها اعلان الاعلان الذي سبق
قمه الجزائر اللي هي قبل الاخيره
في الجزائر وبالتالي ظل يعني توحد الجبهه
الداخليه الفلسطينيه حلما
يراودنا واتمنى يعني هذا بقى ليس تنبؤ
بالمعنى الدقيق ولكنه امنيه مبنيه على
تطورات طوفان الاقصى لان طوفان الاقصى كان
عملا قادته حماس لم تقم به حماس وحدها
ولكنها قادته ولاحظنا وهذه ملاحظه شديده
الايجابيه ان الرس محمود عباس على راس
السلطه الفلسطينيه ابدى تفهما كاملا لهذا
العمل وبالتالي امنيتي ان يكون مستقبل
السلطه الفلسطينيه ان تتحول بالفعل الى
سلطه فلسطينيه بمعنى انها تعبر عن كافه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه حتى الان طبعا حماس
مستبعده بسبب الانقسام وغيرها يعني فاتمنى
ان يكون
ان تكون احداث طوفان الاقصى هي البدايه
الحقيقيه للوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه هذا
على مستوى الامنيات وطبعا الامنيات يعني
لكنها امنيات لها اساس موضوعي هذه المره
تمام ولكن انا عندي سؤال واستاذن لو ممكن
بايجاز ونتطرق اليه لان ده محتاج حلقه
كامله انا لا اعرف ماذا تفعل السلطه يعني
انا ممكن اختلف مع حماس لكن هي لها دور
مفهوم ا قد تتفق او تختلف مع الجهاد لكن
دورها وسياستها مفهومه لكن انا مش فاهم
يعني وضع السلطه ا علامات على شرعيتها
بقاء الرئيس سنوات طويله جدا دون اي
انتخابات او تجديد ليس هناك دورا واضح هل
انا كده
يعني اقصو عليهم ولا حضرتك تشاركني انه في
علامات استفهام على السلطه نفسها شوف هي
السلطه الفلسطينيه بسبب الملابسات المحيطه
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه ككل لا دور اساسيا لها
في القضيه الكبرى وهي تسويه او حل القضيه
الفلسطينيه لان الموضوع اكبر من قدرات
السلطه لكن السلطه اولا تعبر عن الموقف
الفلسطيني الوطني العام دون فعاليه لان
قدرتها محدوده وهي ثانيا تدير الحياه
اليوميه في الضفه
ا الغربيه لذلك قلت انه اتمنى ان تكون
هناك كما ان نتنياهو دع الى حكومه وحده
وطنيه اتمنى ان نستغل الظرف الموضوعي الذي
حدث في عبور الانقسام بين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وتكوين حكومه وحده وطنيه
فلسطينيه لا شك انه سوف يكون او سوف تكون
لها تاثيرات بالغه الايجابيه على
الاداء الفلسطيني استاذنك في في سؤال مرجا
لانه انا عندي يعني اسئله كثيره من
المتابعين
يعني لكن اتمنى ان نخصص حلقه لمستقبل
السلطه بعد مرحله الرئيس
محمود عباس ابو مازن يعني ربنا يديله
الصحه وطوله العمر ولكن بديهي يعني انه
يكون في مرحله جديده فاستاذنتها
الشرعيه ليست مشكله فلسطينيه فقط لو
تابعنا اوضاع عدد من الدول العربيه سنجد
ان نفس المشكله قائمه اه طبعا الشرعيه ده
صحيح ده صحيح بس بما ان احنا كنا بنتكلم
على السلطه الفلسطينيه عندي السؤال الثالث
في الحلقه ديت هل
تتخيل قصدي كيف تتصور تاثير طوفان الاقصى
على توجهات الدول التي طبعت او التي تسعى
الى مزيد من
التطبيع يعني اتصور يعني هل هل مثلا ممكن
تسير م مثلا الرغبه اللي بنسمع عنها من
امريكا واسرائيل ولا نسمع عنها كثيرا مجرد
التلميحات من السعوديه ان تمشي في قطار
التطبيع مع اسرائيل هل يمكن ان يستمر حماس
مثلا بعض الحكومات زي الامارات والبحرين
في التطبيع الساخن مع اسرائيل الموقف في
المغرب الى اخره هو انا يعني اتصور اولا
ان قطار التطبيع ماض في طريق
لانه بيعكس تغيرات في توجهات بعض النخب
العربيه الحاكمه تجاه اسرائيل ولكن بسبب
احداث طوفان الاقصى فان هذا القطار سيهدد
من سرعته يعني دعنا مثلا نتخيل يعني تاثير
هذا التدمير الذي قامت به اسرائيل امس
واول امس في قطاع غزه اعتقد انه لابد وان
يعر الى بعض الخطوات يعني هذا منطقي فانا
تصوري ان دوافع التطبيع لدى بعض النخب
العربيه الحاكمه ستبقى قائمه ولكن احداث
طوفان الاقصى وان لم تغير من هذه الدوافع
لكنها بالتاكيد ستؤثر على سرعه قطار
التطبيق هم شايفين ان مصالحهم في علاقه
قويه مع مع الاسرائيليين ما هو هذا ما
قصدته بالحديث عن
الدوافع وان كنت الحقيقه قد لا اتفهم هذا
كثيرا لكن الدوافع موجوده وكت الحليل
واقعي لا اتصور ان طوفان الاقصى سيضع
نهايه لمسار
التطبيق سؤال رابع طبعا مطروح يعني من
سنين طويله هو تصور حضرتك لمستقبل اسرائيل
الكلام ده كنا بيطرح مع الازمات الكبيره
مع الانتصارات بعتقد ان اسرائيل يعني هي
خلاص يعني قدر محتوم وبنتكلم على مستقبل
الدول العربيه الان جماعه زي
حماس في الاخر هي ميليشيات جماعات يعني
ماهش ليست دوله استطاعت ان تذل الجيش
الاسرائيلي وانا بستخدم تعبير لا اعتقد ان
فيه مبالغه والكلام اللي كان بيقول ما
الشيخ حسن نصر مره قال عليه طبعا كنا بنعت
انه بيبغ ان هذا مثل بيت العنكبوت لا
تخشوهم يعني يبدو ان الراجل ما كانش
بيبالغوا هل تعتقد حضرتك اذا كنت بتتفق او
بتختلف مع هذه التقديرات
انه يجب ان نطرح سؤال الان على مستقبل
اسرائيل يعني هل اسرائيل الى زوال اسرائيل
موجوده واذا زالت كيف
تزول على فكره الحديث عن مستقبل اسرائيل
وكيف انه الى زوال موجود حتى في دوائر
اسرائيليه وانا ربما السؤال كان مفاجئا لي
لكن اذكر ان هناك
فيلما اسرائيليا تحدث عن هذا وانه يعني
الزوال سيكون بتوحد العرب والمسلمين وماذا
ربما اذا لم تخني الذاكره كان اسمه
2048 اشاره الى السنه التي ده فيلم ايه
جنسيهه ايه اسرائيلي فيلم اسرائيلي فيلم
اسرائيلي واعتقد ا ايضا انه كان هناك كتاب
او روايه او شيء من هذا القبيل هاجس زوال
اسرائيل اذا موجود لدى افراد من النخبه
الاسرائيليه المثقفه النقطه الثانيه ان
طبعا هناك
من يتحدث عن زوال اسرائيل بنبوت دينيه
وانا لا استطيع ان افتي في هذا انما البعض
يقول انه نبوءات دينيه تشير الى هذا
الزوال اتجاه ثالث يتحدث عن خبره التاريخ
انه لم يحدث ان استمر كيان يهودي اظن اكثر
من 80 عاما او شيء من هذا القبيل اذا
الحديث عن زوال اسرائيل حديث متكرر لكن
انا احب ان انهج الى هذا الموضوع نهجا
علميا افهم فيه اسرائيل بالنسبه لي ظاهره
استعماريه وقانون التحرر الوطني كما اسميه
يؤدي او يفضي يفيد بانه اي ظاهره
استعماريه الى زوال بعد عصر بقى الهنود
والحمر س حضرتك الاستثناء الاستراليين
والامريكان لا لا هذه كانت في ظروف اخرى
مغيره تماما دوليا ومن كل الزوايا لكن
لنقل مثلا في
اعقاب يعني ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لم يحدث ان ظاهره استعماريه قد بقيت اللهم
الا الحاله الفلسطينيه وكانت اخر حاله
لظاهره استعماريه استيطانيا هي جنوب
افريقيا التي تمت تصفيتها في تسعينات
القرن ا الماضي وبالتالي علميا كل استعمار
الى زوال ولكن هو السؤال ما هي الكيفيه
التي سيزول بها الاستعمار الصهيوني
لفلسطين هنا انا
ارجح او اميل الى ان نموذج جنوب افريقيا
هو الانسب لانه نموذج جنوب افريقيا فيه
مستوطنون نبيض من القرن الثام عشر في جنوب
افريقيا وفيه نفس الكلام الذي ذكرته في
الحلقه الماضيه انه قانون الفعل ورد الفعل
الاستعمار والمقاومه وفيه مقاومه الشعب في
جنوب افريقيا اولا
بالسلاح عندما شكل نيلسون منديلا تنظيم
رمح الامه ثم اكتشف بعبقريته السياسيه انه
الكفاح المسلح وحده لا يكفي او لن يفضي
الى تحقيق الهدف فبدات مرحله النضال
المدني ا السلمي وهذه على فكره ورقه مهمه
جدا في النضال الفلسطيني ان شاء الله
فبدات مرحله النضال المدني السلمي التي
اخذت في التصاعد حتى اقتنع المجتمع الدولي
ب يعني
حق المواطنون السود الاصليون في جنوب
افريقيا في الاستقلال ومن هنا جاء الحل
التاريخي ان هو حل ديمقراطي و مان وان فوت
صوت لكله الكل سواسيه الكل سواسيه وعندما
طبق هذا المبدا وصلت الاغلبيه السوداء الى
الحكم مع ملاحظه مهمه ان البعض يتصور ان
الديمقراطيه هي حكم الاغلبيه وهذا صحيح
ولكن حكم الاغلبيه التي لا تستهين بحقوق
الاقليه وبالتالي رغم ان السود وصلوا الى
الحكم انما كانت هناك ضمانات حقيقيه
للاقليه البيضاء في حاله اسرائيل الامور
هتكون اسهل لانه اليهود لن يكونوا اقليه
قليله
وبالتالي النموذج عندما نتحدث عن زوال
اسرائيل كظاهره استعماريه لا نتحدث عن
زوالها ككيان مادي ولكن نتحدث عن تغيير
بنيتها السياسيه بحيث لا تكون دوله عنصريه
وانما دوله تتسع لمكوناتها من اليهود
والعرب ويعني لتاتي الديمقراطيه بما تاتي
به وبضم مانات محدده طبعا هذا حل يعني
اولا اننا يعني ان حل
الدولتين لا يعني زوال اسرائيل وفي للاسف
ان اسرائيل تحارب هذا الحل مع ان هو
الضامن الاكبر لها ان تظل في حدودها قبل
67 تفعل ما تشاء وان يعني تقبل وجود دوله
فلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه بما
ان اسرائيل حتى الان من الناحيه العمليه
لا تتخيل هذا الحل وان كان للامانه بعض
الفصائل في اسرائيل او بعض النخب لا مانع
لديها من حل الدولتين كان اخرهم لبيد لما
اعل قب
لحل لكن اذا استمر هذا الحل مغلقا فسيكون
التصور التاريخي لزوال دوله اسرائيل ليس
زوالها ماديا ولكن تغيير ضيعتها بحيث
تتحول من نظام استعماري عنصري الى نظام
ديمقراطي يسع اليهو والعرب معا بحقوق
متساويه اذا حضرتك بتتصور انه اذا صارت
الامور على هذا النهج الحتميه التاريخيه
انه زوال اسرائيل مش بالتدمير مواطنيها
ولكن بان تكون يعني حل الدوله الواحده
انها دوله واحده بتتس للفلسطينيين وبتتسلي
العرب واليهود مع فلم بان هذا طبعا يتطلب
نضالا شاقا يستمر عقودا نهايه اسرائيل في
حل الدوله الواحده صحيح مش كده يعني وان
طل المطل جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور الله
يخليك شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم وان شاء الله
بنان في الحديث مع الدكتور احمد يوسف
في سواء في الشان الفلسطيني او في كافه
الشؤون العربيه في حلقات اخرى باذن الله
اشكركم والى اللقاء